les maîtres du soleil c'était ce matin à
limoges l'avant-première de ce film
signé par jean jacques au blanc son
deuxième film ce film va sortir en
limousin dans six salles le 18 avril
notamment à brive à tulle à guéret avec
le temps et bien sûr à saint léonard
alors marcela monde dans ce film les
maîtres du soleil et tourné par notre
ami jean jacques au blanc vous n'êtes
pas blindé m du sol et vous êtes victor
le jardinier qui tout de même
s'intéresse à à cette lumière pure qui
va sortir ici de monségur c'est une
reconversion le cinéma pour vous j'ai
toujours j'en ai toujours fait plus ou
moins sporadiquement nous diront c'est
giraudoux et le cinéma depuis vingt ans
et il a fallu que cet enfant du pays
font d'ailleurs regardez ce beau teint
de porcelaine là bas jean-jacques robe
blanche nous demande de participer à
cette aventure scientifique au policière
alors au milieu de tous ces savants sont
un peu fous ils ont découvert des choses
qu'ils auront tourneboulé un petit peu
la tête et moi je suis effectivement
jardiniers du lycée je sais comme une
carte mère je prends une règle alors je
suis je suis devenu très copain avec ce
monsieur qui est professeur qui montre
aux blancs du doigt voyez ces hauts
blancs là et donc je l'accompagné dans
sa course avec la police aux fesses et
bon ses 7,7
ces événements tout à fait
exceptionnelle ne me l'enlèverez rien
mon bon sens et de ma gaieté
j'ai donc fait à peine un personnage de
composition
je vois qu'ils me jette des regards
furibard mc grands signes il a peur que
j'oublie de dire que en matinée mercredi
on est à deux heures à à guéret ainsi
que le soir à 20 heures et le soir il
nous fait il nous fait pas perdre de
temps et le soir on est à brive pour un
débat voilà je crois que j'ai tout dis
peut-être pas tout à fait mort c'est
l'amour donc vous avez fait en fête du
cinéma aux il ya vingt ans je compte ne
pas tourner de films
alors donc c'est un retour au cinéma
avec les maîtres du soleil mais la
chanson honnête vous on a quoi on à 2008
a encore la main ça vous savez si vous
ne les trois heures je pourrai commencer
à vous expliquer ce qui se passe je suis
un monsieur qui j'ai débuté dans la
profession artistique
j'ai commencé par la scène un gt j'y
joue les vallées de molière ici et là et
je suis devenu un chanteur mais à
l'époque je vous parle pas de la guerre
de 14
je vous parle de mon jeune mes débuts de
chanteur ont fait ils ont commencé par
la scène et pendant 6 ou 7 ans j'ai fait
de la scène sans faire du disque même
temps depuis les années 60 les carrières
je plains les chanteurs débutants qui
n'ont pas la chance d'émerger tout de
suite les carrières sont ont été
subordonnées à la l'industrie du disque
alors je veux pas cracher dans mon
atelier de temps en temps je vends du
disque mais je continue à être nomme de
cette voie là je vois qu'il est
trente-et-une et 49 secondes 50
maintenant ce retour aussi les mains me
permet de faire plusieurs choses et de
ne pas trop m'en veux rester dans mon
sillon mars et là bonjour ou mars et là
moi je crois qu'on va vous voir
également très prochainement dans des
spots publicitaires
c'est aussi une nouvelle carrière non
vous savez pendant des années j'ai
refusé
on va pas me voir dans des spots
publicitaires vraiment engagé 55 ans ça
sera la première fois que j'en fais et
puisque tout le monde ne fait que c'est
pas déshonorant du tout pourquoi ne le
ferais je pas voilà il peut être d'un
autre film avec jean jacques hublin
merci marc seul homme